[Música]
hola me llamo fresar estudié ingeniería
química y me dedico a la promoción
cultural
cada vez que paso por una avenida en mi
ciudad monterrey que se llama lázaro
cárdenas hay un letrero que me llama
mucho la atención dice algo más o menos
así elige tu destino oportunamente
siempre que lo veo me hace reflexionar
qué tan oportuna oportunamente debo
elegir mi destino y qué destino debo
elegir
ahora les contaré cuál fue mi
experiencia eligiendo la carrera que
estudie
me gradué de prepa a los 16 años y la
asesora de orientación vocacional me
dijo tienes puro 10 en mata y en química
estudia ingeniería
cuando fui a pedir informes a rectoría
del tec de monterrey entré al edificio y
un aroma al libros y en madera fina me
invadió ese olor todavía me recuerda en
mis años universitarios
sobre una mesa muy larga estaban todos
los folletos con portadas de diferentes
colores brillantes en ese momento no
había internet así que esa era mi única
oportunidad de saber cuáles eran los
planes de estudio
tomé los que me parecieron más
atractivos por su color ingeniería en
electrónica ciencias de la comunicación
contaduría pública
ingeniero químico administrador
todas traían descripciones muy
interesantes de las carreras y los
nombres desde las materias eran bastante
atractivos pero al mismo tiempo confusos
así que me llevé los folletos a mi casa
y los estudie uno a uno detenidamente
a la hora de decidirme pensé mi papá es
ingeniero y le va muy bien
en la bolsa de trabajo hay muchas
vacantes de ingeniería así es que sin
pensarlo más me inscribí a ingeniero
químico y quad
les confieso que no fue nada fácil esa
carrera que probé varias materias y en
los cuatro años y medios que estuve
estudiando varias veces me asaltó la
duda de si realmente había tomado la
decisión correcta
pero pues ya estaba encaminado en eso y
terminé y me gradué
sobre todo cuando empezaba al cada
semestre había materias que tenían
nombres rarísimos como fenómenos de
transporte termodinámica transferencia
de momentum en fin
mi primer trabajo fue en una fábrica de
pisos de cerámica en el laboratorio
yo creo que me desempeñé bien algunos
años en eso según yo me sentía súper
importante con mi bata con mis lentes de
seguridad mis zapatos y mi casco pero
había algo en mí que me hacía no estar
completamente satisfecho
en mi tiempo libre me puse a estudiar
literatura teatro artes y hubo un
momento después de más o menos nueve
años en que decidí que necesitaba un
cambio
me sorprendía como otros compañeros míos
que trabajaban en la industria química
tenían mucho éxito y se sentían felices
con lo que hacía yo sentía que algo me
faltaba
fue una de las decisiones más difíciles
de mi vida renunciar sin tener un plan
de confieso que pasé varios meses
navegando en qué hacer fui a muchas
entrevistas de trabajo pero en casi
todas se trataba de hacer lo mismo que
yo ya no quería seguir haciendo
afortunadamente un día llegó a mí una
oportunidad que combinaba todo el
conocimiento que yo tenía con la
organización de eventos
afortunadamente tuve mucho que aprender
pero la capacitación que tenía como
ingeniero me ayudó a lograrlo
si de algo estoy agradecido con mis
maestros es que me enseñaron a resolver
problemas complejos y sobre todo a
buscarle una solución a todo
y así empezó mi carrera como gestor y
promotor cultural primero en eventos que
tenían que ver con publicidad y luego ya
más adelante con cosas que tenían que
ver más con las artes
ahora que lo veo a la distancia a los 16
años tenía muy poca madurez como para
saber a quién quería dedicar el resto de
mi vida
con el paso de los años he aprendido que
lo que más disfrutas es algo que puede
ser tu carrera por eso en los siguientes
momentos en que he tenido que tomar la
decisión de cambiar de trabajo me he
enfocado en buscar las cosas que más le
satisfacen y que pueden enriquecer mi
nueva trayectoria profesional
tal vez no les quede claro lo que la
promoción cultural puede ser y por qué
para mí es una forma de vida lo voy a
poner de esta manera yo lo mido por los
logros que se pueden obtener
por ejemplo un financiero busca tener
mayores rendimientos para las
inversiones de sus clientes
en mi caso a mí me causa una gran
emoción el darme cuenta cómo el arte
transforma las personas
en una ocasión me logro me tocó
organizar un concierto para un grupo que
se llama paté de fuá yo no los conocía
pero resulta que tenían muchísimos
seguidores
por un problema con el audio el grupo no
se pudo presentar y fue a mí al que le
tocó subirme al escenario y pedir
disculpas a la gente diciéndoles que el
concierto se cancelaba pero que les
prometía que al día siguiente se iban a
volver a presentar
esas 24 horas para mí fueron una odisea
tratando de conseguir un equipo de
sonido que cumpliera las características
que el grupo necesitaba y sin embargo lo
logré como lo prometí al día siguiente
el grupo se presentó con éxito y la
verdad es que para mí el ver a la gente
como disfrutaba el concierto ver a las
parejas bailando o bailando con sus
familias ver a personas que llegaban
apáticas y luego salían complacidas y
conviviendo en armonía significó una
gran satisfacción que me motivó en ese
momento y me sigue motivando actualmente
para continuar haciendo lo que hago
aunque ese día termine con migraña
algunos de ustedes están en un momento
crítico en el que tienen que decidir qué
carrera estudiar
elegir su destino
oportunamente
yo les recomiendo que no se agobien que
tomen las cosas con calma y que al final
de cuentas tarde o temprano la vocación
les va a llegar
pero como saber cuál es mi vocación
no tengo la respuesta porque no hay una
fórmula a mí lo que me funcionó fue auto
analizar me e identificar las cosas que
me causan más sentimiento de éxito y las
que me provocan más satisfacción
también creo que es muy importante que
si logramos identificar cuál es el
beneficio de lo que vamos a hacer
podamos tomar una decisión
por ejemplo un ingeniero en electrónica
no diseña un teléfono para que la voz se
traslada de un lugar a otro lo hace para
que las personas estén comunicadas con
sus seres queridos para que estén cerca
para poder compartir nuestras ideas y
conocimientos y en cierto momento
inclusive hasta para cambiar el mundo
para mejor
también es importante buscar a un
profesional de la orientación vocacional
que nos ayude y cuando ya tengamos dos o
tres opciones de lo que queremos
estudiar busquemos a gente que ya se
dedique a eso y platicamos con ella le
preguntemos cómo ha sido su experiencia
cuáles han sido sus retos más difíciles
y sobre todo cuáles han sido sus éxitos
más satisfactorias se van a sorprender
viendo que en la gran mayoría de los
casos el factor económico no es
importante
así me pasó a mí después que conseguir
ese trabajo donde pudiera desarrollar
mis conocimientos con lo que me daba más
satisfacción entendí varias cosas
que es muy válido empezar de cero
que podemos equivocarnos si sabemos
retomar el rumbo oportunamente y que es
mucho mejor arriesgarse y tomar acción
que quedarnos esperando a que las cosas
sucedan por sí solas
por último los invito a reflexionar
acerca de ese pero que dice elige tu
destino oportunamente no nos está
invitando a que elijamos nuestro destino
ya
sino a que tomemos nuestro tiempo nos
relajemos y pensemos que oportuna en
oportunamente tarde o temprano el
destino va a llegar siempre que
disfrutemos lo que hagamos